welcome to the 100th episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast join me in
celebrating with two special guests the
head of Microsoft's business AI division
and a lead researcher for aerial
informatics and robotics as we explore
how the power of simulation is paving
the way for robust autonomous systems in
real world situations you're listening
to the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen heusinger there's
a lot of excitement around self-driving
cars delivery drones and other
intelligent autonomous systems but
before they can be deployed at scale
they need to be both reliable and safe
that's like your deep paul c vp of
business AI at Microsoft and dr. Ashish
Kapoor who leads research and aerial
informatics and robotics are using a
simulated environment called air sim to
reduce the time cost and risk of the
testing necessary to get autonomous
agents ready for the open world today
Guardian Ashish discussed life at the
intersection of machine learning
simulation and autonomous systems and
talked about the challenges we face as
we transition from a world of automation
to a world of autonomy they also tell us
about game of drones an exciting new
drone racing competition where the goal
is to imbue flying robots with human
level perception and decision-making
skills on the fly that and much more on
this episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
I want to welcome everyone to are you
ready the hundredth episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast this is going
to be a fun show because with me I have
great Paul who is a corporate vice
president at Microsoft and head of the
business AI division and he leads the AI
and research leadership team and beside
him is dr. Rajesh Kapoor who is a
podcast alum my guest on episode 22
welcome back yeah thank you
and Ashish is the senior principal
research manager for the Ariel
informatics and robotics group and
Microsoft aka err I'm glad to have you
both here
on this special episode welcome to the
podcast Grady Paul and ashish kapoor
yeah thank you very much very excited to
be here yeah likewise really excited so
I've just introduced you briefly but I'd
like each of you to give a little more
detail on what you do for a living
let's start with you good deep you've
worn a lot of hats here at Microsoft and
in other places as well what's your
focus now what gets you up in the
morning right now I'm focused on
bringing emergent AI to interesting
business problems and I couldn't imagine
at this point my career working on
something more exciting because the way
we think of it yeah is the fourth
Industrial Revolution so to the extent
that we can bring AI into all these
different domains around us is one of
the most exciting opportunities I think
ever and certainly for my career is that
your mandate then is to bring AI to the
world at large yes exactly so with a
slightly more focused way in the sense
that you know AI of course can be
applied to many things and Microsoft has
lots of products and you can infuse AI
into those products my focus is how do
you create new businesses with emergent
AI Ashish give us a drones eye view of
your work and what you're doing what get
you up in the morning so I would say I'm
very blessed to work in an organization
where we have the opportunity to pursue
some of the ambitions specifically what
I do at my
soft is lead a research group that's
working at the intersection of
autonomous systems machine learning and
simulation so specifically what we are
interested in is building these
intelligent agents and when you think
about intelligence machine learning and
artificial intelligence have a big role
to play in that and so what we're trying
to do is take a look at some of the I
would say techniques on the edge
innovate in those techniques and thence
try to solve this hard problem in
autonomy people have been doing machine
learning for several decades now but
most of the machine learning right now
stops at making predictions but when you
start building systems that act upon
those things that's when things get
interesting
and that's what we do that's what we
start to think about how we can bring
these machine intelligence machining
techniques and apply to systems which
act upon it and autonomous systems are a
great example that need to act upon this
kind of inferences that machine learning
folks have been doing for years before
we really get into it
I'd like to establish for our listeners
why the two of you are here together
obviously grew deep here the business
side of AI and as she share the research
side of AI but describe your
relationship in terms of how you know
each other and how you work together
great
I'll start so you know it's part of my
charter to look at emergent AI and see
if new businesses can be created with it
the mo that I have is actually very
simple I just spent a lot of time
talking to MSR folks you know Eric Peter
and folks inside their organizations and
I'm basically looking at what area has
come far enough along that this
potentially can be channeled towards an
existing business problem you know I've
known above ashish for a long time when
eric Horvitz used to talk about him all
the time
and then you know I got to understand
the work that he was doing so as we were
thinking about this sort of overarching
autonomous system thing it was very
natural for me to work closely with
Ashish and then eventually as is pretty
common with the areas that we have in
business here I moved into my team
because typically we have research
Engineering and business folks all
together working closely on one
particular mission so Ashish is heading
up the research side of that okay
so we were part of core Microsoft
Research and it was apparent that the
impact of some of the work that was
happening in our group went beyond just
the research impact it had the potential
to empower a lot of machine learning
developers and researchers who might
want to foray into robotics for instance
while in research we have expertise in
catering to research crowd so
specifically writing papers and talking
about academia in fact we had a lot of
folks from academia looking into it and
slowly it trickled into other parts of
engineering as well and it made sense
for us to you know start thinking
something bigger than academia something
bigger than research and the technology
is mature enough but it needs guidance
and I would say experience of folks who
can build businesses around it right so
consequently I'm a research team
embedded in the larger organization
where we continue to innovate and work
on technology while keeping an eye on
how it can empower and be useful to
other folks and you know I'll add to
that you know Ashish is a researcher but
what I really think makes him almost
like a perfect for the business SIA
organization is because he really wants
to bring that research into real-world
solutions and I think that desire is
very important because a lot of times
you know research was preferred to
continue pursuing what they're you know
very interested in from a research angle
perspective but he's very interested in
how that can actually be commercialized
or can have a bigger impact so in that
sense it's really great to have them
yeah and and likewise I would say right
I mean if you're building a business
instead of just thinking about the
monetary aspects I mean you know we have
the support where the research aspects
are equally important in fact we are at
the center of it so having that kind of
balance is very important so it's a
great place to be
Pradeep Microsoft is not the only
company exploring autonomous systems
talk about the broader ecosystem in this
field and Microsoft's position within it
may be starting with your perspective on
Microsoft's evolving role in society
and how the company's goals evolved with
it these are great questions so you know
I think at the highest level I think one
way to think of what's happening around
us is you know we are really at the
onset of the fourth Industrial
Revolution if you look at what happened
with the first Industrial Revolution
with the steam engine and the factories
that got created with it I mean in
change societies this whole notion of
child care you know didn't exist before
the first Industrial Revolution and the
reason it came up is because people for
the first time left their larger
families and moved into these towns
which are built around these factories
that's the kind of far-reaching impact
the first Industrial Revolution had and
then each one of them had a similar
impact as well and I think this fourth
Industrial Revolution is going to be
just about as dramatic maybe more and I
think we just have to prepare for that
but coming down to you know specifically
what we are focused on yeah today we see
a big shift from automation slowly
towards autonomy hmm now automation has
basically enabled the level of
productivity that you see today but
automation is very fragile inflexible
expensive it's very cumbersome once you
set them up and then everything is
working well it's fantastic and that is
what we live at today
you know autonomous systems we think can
actually make that lot easier now the
broad industry is really still oriented
towards automation so we have to bring
that industry over slowly into this
autonomous world and what's interesting
is while these folks are experts in
mechanical engineering and operations
research and you know all those kind of
important capabilities and logistics
they don't know AI very much they don't
know how to create horizontal tool
chains which enable efficient
development and operations of these type
of systems so that's the expertise we
bring add that one more point to it is
that the places we are seeing autonomous
systems being built like autonomous
driving they're actually building it in
a very very vertical way and in some
ways that's a bit of a
you see of how robotic systems have been
built in the past and we don't think
that's the scaleable way because there's
going to be literally thousands and
thousands thousands different kinds of
autonomous systems so you need these
horizontal building blocks yeah and
that's what we focused on Ashish I want
you to answer the same question but
perhaps from a research perspective and
where you see Microsoft Research and
Microsoft in general as a player in this
space what's - what's hope and what's
real you know automation is where
everyone has been focusing on and
autonomy promises to make these things
simpler because now your automation is
more robust it has the ability to decide
when things are not correct and correct
them if needed
and of course folks have been going
after certain vertical like self-driving
and they are spending billions of
dollars what if I want to have a
different kind of robot that has similar
kind of capability do I go and spend a
few billion dollars again to do that
probably not you got it though yes also
on the other hand from the research
perspective we are increasingly seeing
the impact of machine learning
technologies on robotics so new
technology such as reinforcement
learning imitation learning and now you
know also unsupervised or cell
supervised learning are playing bigger
and bigger part in autonomy and robotics
my background is in machine learning and
the way I went to robotics was you know
I there was a vertical that I really
cared about but it was extremely
difficult to get into robotics you not
only need to worry about hardware you
also have to worry about orchestration
of things you know having several people
making sure things are safe if your
robot does something stupid it breaks
down and then you're stuck for a few
days so consequently a lot of our work
in the group have focused on removing
some of these obstacles if you are a
machine learning researcher developer if
you are a programmer and if you want to
build a robot what can we bring to you
so that the process for automating and
making something autonomous is much
simpler so that you don't have to spend
billions of dollars trying to create
your ecosystems and everything right
it's a tool change there are modular
parts
there are things like simulations there
are things like deep learning
methodologies there are algorithms that
you can mix and match almost like Legos
and can we enable that my brain is going
in a thousand directions now because of
you too thank you very much I want to
put a little finer point on the
difference between automated and
autonomous they both share the same root
word what's the fine differentiation
there the main differentiation is that
let's say you're a BMW car assembly line
and today most car assembly is done by
robots now let's say BMW is launching a
new car line they now need to basically
configure that entire assembly line with
each station to perform different tasks
today the way this line is assembled is
that these robots they know that exactly
at this point in the XYZ space that they
need to stop the arm and then they need
to basically have certain torque said
that's all it does and it moves out of
the way new car comes in they go exactly
with the point and they turn it and it
goes on right got it
so now if the car happened to stop half
an inch before it's gonna come to that
same point and then it's gonna have a
big problem that is automation for you
when everything is working exactly
correctly it is like fast exactly in
autonomous world the arm has to find
this particular place and now this thing
seeks and finds the right place even if
it is you know five inches this way on
top and it'll find it and it'll just
align itself correctly and then go for
it that is autonomous okay where it has
certain level of planning capability and
then control capability to deal with
unforeseen situations so the autonomous
setup is upstream of the automated
because it's still going to be running
the same kind of thing but you're giving
it a brain exactly
[Music]
let's get technical
you've just alluded to machine learning
and some various flavors therein and I
really want to talk about reinforcement
learning now especially because it seems
to be the brains behind the autonomous
systems we're talking about so gurdy
would you start by talking about the
machine learning landscape in the
various methodologies that are involved
sure when we talk about AI today
probably the most prevalent methodology
is something called supervised learning
and supervised learning the way those
algorithms work is that you have a lot
of data and you have labels for the data
which basically tell the algorithm how
it should adjust its weights then you
have unsupervised learning which is on
the other extreme where you get lots and
lots of data but you really don't have
much labels and the algorithm is to make
sense of it and then you have
semi-supervised to Samos it's in the
middle where you're may have some data
or some of the Machine figures out and
you know those methods have worked very
well for certain kind of problems right
like for example it's a language if you
want to train our speech stack to
basically pick up a new language and
train for it it's pretty easy you get
thousand hours of label data and you
know these are very sophisticated they
can go pretty much they learn up to a
certain level of performance what
happens for problems that exist in the
real world is that either it's very
difficult to capture the data or it is
nearly impossible to capture all the
data that you would ever need to operate
inside that so reinforcement learning is
another approach to AI which basically
says that I'm gonna learn by actually
taking action in the real world and
every time take action I get smarter and
in some ways you know this model is how
humans learn as well so at a high level
that's what reinforcement learning is
and the way it is actually implemented
practically is that you know you have
the state which is the state
that you're acting against the algorithm
will take an action in the state changes
and you get a reward back whether you're
getting closer or farther from your
objective and then that point you take
the next action you get a reward back
and you stay in this loop eventually you
figure it out okay so that's
reinforcement learning for you so Ashish
when we talked we've talked many times
you were mentioning how reinforcement
learning has been really successful in
game scenarios and when we get into the
open world it's a whole different ball
of wax
you gave us an overview a little over a
year ago on air sim and why simulation
is important in this particular milieu
review for us for those of our listeners
who have not heard that podcast tell us
what air sim is and why the sim part is
so important when we talk about these
kinds of systems so air sim aspires to
be a new realistic simulation for AI and
robotics systems so in a nutshell it's
video game on steroids that software's
are playing and the game comprises of a
robotic agent that's operating in an
environment which is akin to reality so
good they've just mentioned about
technologies such as reinforcement
learning and imitation learning which
are trying to solve this decision making
problem so as an autonomous agent you
need to make decisions and decisions are
not just about now but it also needs to
factor into account the future
consequences as well and that's what
makes them hard so for instance when you
playing games so things like NGO or
Atari games or pac-man or any other
video game right as a gamer you have a
sense of what your actions right now
have a consequence in future and in
order to make that effect into your
machine learning you need to play
millions and millions of time so for
instance you know Atari games you know
we've been hearing about how machine
learning can solve some of these video
games at superhuman level almost getting
perfect score for instance some of the
recent work at Microsoft Research in
Montreal talks about pac-man but one
thing you need to realize is that you
are trying to play these games several
hundred millions
times before something reasonable starts
to appear as a policy we do not have
such luxury in real world I cannot have
a robot bonk into things a million times
before I start to learn something new so
consequently simulation and more
importantly these simulations with cloud
compute like you can have you know
millions of instances on Azure where
these robotic systems which at the back
end have a deep neural network or some
kind of machine learning agent guiding
them you gathers these experiences and
we can do that very quickly we don't
have to wait days and days and we don't
have to ruin hundreds of millions of
robots you can do everything in
simulation get this data and given that
air Simha is trying to be near realistic
the data that you gather is fairly close
to reality so you can hope that the
policies and the machine learning
intelligence that you are generating
will transfer to real world as well okay
so when we talked more than a year ago
this was sort of kind of news right I
would like to know where it is now I
mean what has happened in this last year
has it found traction Arison was
released as an open source project two
and a half years ago and since then
we've seen increased usage there are
several hundred folks using it for sure
and then there are some very close
Academy collaborators that have used
technologies based on air sim to solve
very difficult problems for instance
collaborators at USC they have been
using air sim to Train computer vision
models to recognize poachers from drones
that are flying over Savannah so you
know you can imagine how difficult that
problem is that you have some drone
flying at night or Savannah and your
goal is to detect all of these warm
bodies beat animals or poachers and
which a few pixel big again where do you
get real-world data for that yeah so
consequently a soon to the risk you wave
you instantiate the entire Savannah and
simulation and start collecting data at
scale so that's one example and
similarly I mean folks have trained
racing cars so for instance our
collaborators in Technion they have
built an SAE racing karts of essays
society of automotive engineer and
they have a competition on f1 racing
cars but autonomous and so they train
their perception models in air seem to
do the controls
so people are solving very hard
challenges in autonomy using this
technology and very different ones I
mean from poachers to f1 racing cars my
mouth is open right now it's like mind
boggling and interesting I would add to
that I mean it's about nine thousand
stars on yeah it is yeah it's at nine
thousand stars
ursin mouth is still open well I want to
talk about game of drones and this is a
competition that's coming up for nur ups
2019 Ashish before I talk to you this
week I was actually unaware that drone
racing was a thing let alone a hugely
popular thing and then I went down the
YouTube rabbit hole and saw what it was
and it's amazing and we talked about
simulated drowning
they actually have live drone racing in
empty arenas these guys are in cages and
then the drones are going like Harry
Potter
Quidditch kind of thing I was blown away
so talk about what you're doing in this
arena no pun intended of drone racing
and how game of drones is playing into
that and what you hope to accomplish
from like a research and science
perspective on it so game of drones is a
competition that is being held at new
reps 2019 this was jointly proposed by
Microsoft Stanford University and
University of Zurich so you know this is
in collaboration with academia and it's
trying to solve I would say one of the
hardest problems in autonomy I would
even say that this is one of the goals
to aspire for ultimately like you know
we talk about all these superhuman feats
that AI algorithms can achieve but they
come nowhere close in solving this so
what's really happening in a drone race
in real world when people are playing
with it is that a person is sitting on a
chair and he's wearing goggles and
through this goggles he can see a video
stream through a camera mounted on a
drone that's flying at an incredible
fast rate yeah
and by looking at that video feed a
human brain is able to essentially send
four numbers you know those are the
control commands which is the thrust
your role and pitch right the whole
image gets translated into four numbers
and you can go to youtube and see all
those videos what fantastic idea they
can be flips they can do quick turns I
mean it's amazing like the power of
human brain so the big question is can
you actually have this thing driven by a
software so all your software is seeing
is that camera feed and can you
translate all that information into
useful control signals and more
importantly let's make it even more
challenging it's not just about you
going through that course what if you
are also participating against another
drone so now you start thinking about
strategies as well so it's not just
about obstacle avoidance it's also about
how can I beat my opponent so it's
bringing in all of these difficult
problems which like the intersection of
perception controls and planning and the
hope is that by feeling such a
competition we would start to understand
and what would it take to build
technologies that can solve this hard
problem now mind you trying to do this
in real world is extremely hard because
as I said our algorithms are nowhere
near in solving even one person of this
challenge so consequently we feel this
in simulation so there are courses that
are built in air sim where computers can
try the algorithms and see how well they
fare there is an ongoing leaderboard
where you know you can track your
progress against your opponents and then
there are prizes as well deep what do
you say about this thing you know what
is amazing to me is how relevant this is
in the world I mean you don't even have
to roll out like hundreds of years you
can see how relevant this is gonna be in
the next ten years today people are
making tall claims about autonomous
driving I know it's gonna be this year
it's gonna be next year somebody says 50
years so there's all this going on and
actually what is underlying all that is
that there is this missing piece that
nobody has cracked the missing pieces
that most of the autonomous driving
systems are actually built with
old-school robotics and the problem with
all
school robotics is that it is not
sufficient to solve these complex
problems and that is the missing piece
and this game of drones goes to the
heart of that ogre deep I want you to go
on a little bit there there are some
other big issues on the horizon related
to exactly what you were just talking
about when autonomous systems head to
real world applications and they involve
upstream work with like legal issues
business issues regulatory issues so
even as a shishas team over here is
setting up game of drones and doing
their own research what's going on in
this other Lane you're absolutely right
you know this is sort of a brave new
world with whole bunch of new things
that you open up if you let's say City
of Bellevue right and you know here you
are you just about the time you figured
out how to get traffic right and
coordinating the lights changing you're
driving on a on a mean arterial you know
now suddenly you have delivery robots
you have drones you have self-driving
trucks you have cars you've all these
things going around and now you know
things are messed up all over again
you just start thinking about that
problem and so how are they gonna deal
with this really complex world so I
think you know this is an area of some
of the areas that we're starting to look
at is what kind of solutions they will
need in a world like this
is there from the business perspective
because I would assume the researchers
are just working on the technology I
think it's important to actually from
research point of view take a stand on
this so I'm you know we think deeply
about this in research as well and just
to give you a nugget in our research
group the perspective that we have is
that if the system failure happens you
should be able to find someone some
human who is responsible for it so for
instance if there is an autonomous
system that you have designed a human
tells the system these are the safety
specifications I always want you to be
in these things so if our system fails
because there was something outside of
those specifications as a human's fault
because as a designer he didn't think
about that so there is a philosophy even
in research that we need to adhere to in
our case we take this thing very
seriously
where
say that every mistake needs to be
traced to a responsible human who can
then take corrective action on it I want
to talk a little bit more Ashish about
something you mentioned on airborne
collision avoidance systems and the
whole concept of air traffic controls if
we're talking about flying robots even
now that particular job is really
high-stress and very rule-based
for humans but you've painted a picture
where we're gonna have hundreds of
autonomous vehicles how do you even
begin
so I mean you're absolutely right the
job of ATC is one of the most difficult
one and it's considered most stressful
job in the world because so much is at
stake and these guys do an amazing job
trying to keep us safe while the demand
on the system is increasing and as you
can imagine as you see more and more
drones and flying taxis this system
would not scale so we will have to start
thinking about automated decision-making
so I am again not using the phrase
autonomous but more about automated
decision-making because because you know
there should be some human
accountability as I said but a lot of
tasks should be automated and all most
of the virtue of autonomous systems so
that's where our bond collision
avoidance systems comes into effect if
you have these vehicles which are
broadcasting their state so not just
flying away because it can be cars as
well it can be forklifts it can be
delivery robots but they are
broadcasting the state and their intent
on what they want to do ok then can you
come up with decision-making modules
that operate on each robot so that they
can take care of themselves an example
that I really like to show is if you've
been to Japan you have this intersection
Shibuya where the red lights happen
across and I think 5 or 7 different
intersections merge together and you
have 300 400 people crossing at once and
within you know three minutes everyone
has crossed there are no collisions what
would it take us to build something like
that but again this is right at the
intersection of machine learning
autonomy robotics everything you come up
with brings up new things it's like this
is research
forever right mama needs a new pair of
shoes well there's another competition
that I'd like to talk about Ashish you
and a team of collaborators just
employed your air stem technology to win
a pretty amazing competition called the
DARPA subti challenge subti standing for
subterranean and you want it rather
decisively so tell us about this
challenge and why it was an important
proving ground for air sim yeah so beam
Explorer which was spearheaded by
Carnegie Mellon University and Oregon
State University so they are our close
collaborators and they had been using
air sim for many other research projects
and when they decided to participate in
the DARPA subterranean challenge we had
conversations on how simulation could
help them achieve the mission so just a
quick introduction on what DARPA
subterranean challenges terrains under
the ground be it man-made caves mines
natural caves tunnels etc are very
difficult to navigate and can be very
dangerous
so think about search-and-rescue
operations instead of sending humans
it's very useful if you can have robots
that can navigate that can map that can
go over obstacles and find things so sub
D challenge is centered around that and
our collaborators at CMU and OSU they
have a pretty amazing robotic system
that's designed to address those
challenges however how do they test
these systems how do they get training
data so that these systems can learn to
see objects in these worlds so
consequently we created a simulation
environment that several miles long set
of caves with different kinds of effects
such as fog and wetness and different
objects hidden at different places so
that they can go and test their
algorithms and systems before our team
Explorer needs to solve these in real
world all right so the simulation
environment helps them by validating
their methodologies as well as
collecting training data for the
perception models so the competition
itself was to identify several of these
objects that were lying in a real cave
and you had to send your robots and you
had to identify so the objects for
instance was survivor a backpack
cell phone a drill and I believe a
flashlight so this was a real cave in
real robot in the real robots and they
were all these objects that the team
whoever could go and detect maximum
number of these objects won and so the
simulation prior to gave you an
advantage for executing it in real life
yeah and all the algorithms that would
they rather be you know finding it and
planning and all that would be tested in
this simulation environment and to me I
mean the biggest thing about this other
than achievement of you know winning the
DARPA challenge is always a pretty
swaggy thing but to me what is really
interesting about it this thesis that we
have that you can create these brains in
a simulation environment and you can
perform much much better than anything
else in the real world I mean this got
completely established in fact you know
I hope that the industry ceases are the
tipping point in moving from some of the
old ways of doing things towards kind of
what we are pushing
[Music]
well it's time for what could possibly
go wrong on the Microsoft Research
podcast and when we're talking about
flying robots the answers a lot
so the general risks are pretty obvious
but I know each of you have thought
through some specific challenges that
keep you up at night talk and turn about
issues of safety and trustworthiness of
autonomous systems and how you're
addressing those so that I don't lose
sleep at night debrie let me first frame
it in the context of this industry and
Microsoft and what we've learned you
know the good thing is that there's just
a brief history of computing you know
you don't have to go back to you know
10,000 years I've looked on Windows NT
and you know we thought we were being
very careful about making sure the code
can't be hacked and this and that we had
no idea the moment the internet got
connected and these machines were on the
internet you basically could be attacked
from anywhere and they were such strong
incentives for people for bad actors to
really do the best work we can't afford
to see that happen in the autonomous
system space we have to proactively get
in and say we need to solve these
problems before these systems are
unleashed in the real world because the
consequence of things failing in the
real world is very very high I mean this
is where it gets completely real so that
is the broader context I would say and
by the way I should plug in I mean I
think the work that Eric is driving with
ether I'm a huge fan of that because I
think as a company we've said we are
going to proactively look at AI all up
and you know identify some of these
things and I think in our case in
particular we are looking at even from a
product perspective or the tool chain
that we are building in my team how this
is one of the differentiated pillars we
call it trustworthy autonomy and we've
made it one of the three pillars so that
over time we get more and more
sophisticated and who's using our tool
chain to create autonomous systems can
actually benefit from all that
Ashish what would you add yeah so what
keeps you up at night I mean all those
things that good dimension but I'll
mention one specific thing which keeps
me up at night because something that
you know as a researcher or a
technologist it's hard for me to
influence we are making progress we are
thinking about it and community at large
is getting aware of those things so they
are at least some progress but here is
the deal I think the bay side with the
technology is evolving is very rapid and
I'm afraid that you know the regulation
might not be evolving that quickly but
the reality is the following right now
if you want to build an autonomous
system there are plants out there on the
web anyone who has some kind of an
engineering expertise can just go ahead
and build it very rapidly right and of
course you know a lot of good actors who
are trying to make things better in
autonomous systems they'll play by
regulation all right however many of
those bad actors will not so I think
that's a tension that I don't know how
to resolve so as you to have identified
some things that I think nobody would
argue these are the highest level what
keeps me up at nights on the planet
aside from thinking about it are there
things that you're kind of building or
baking into your research and your
execution that would say hey we got this
absolutely in fact I think that she
should talk about some of the research
work that he's been doing and we are
actively looking to see how we can
productize that okay as part of our
trust with the autonomy pillar and
feature set so yes we are actively
looking at that so safety is very
important not from the point of view of
you know a hacker attacking your system
our cybersecurity flaws and things like
those but also from the fundamental
technology point of view so for instance
your robots or your autonomous systems
they will have sensors and they'll see
the world through very likely a machine
learning system and we know machine
learning systems have problems like bias
as one you know they make mistakes and
when we know that these systems have
problems how do you then assure safety
so that's a big question that we are
trying to answer and the way we are
thinking about is is now building
policies that are optimal in the worst
case so we need to look down to history
and things about how airplanes and
spaceships were designed you know they
solved a fairly difficult problem and
now we can hop onto an airplane without
worrying about a safety what would it
take us to do that and we need to learn
from those fields and we need to look at
the technologies they employed so that's
you know in a nutshell that's what we're
looking into at the end of every podcast
I give my guests the opportunity to say
anything they want to our listeners so
gurdip and Ashish do you have any
parting advice warning wisdom or
predictions what challenges lie ahead
for autonomous systems in your minds if
you are an aspiring roboticist this is
the time to come out the reason being
that you know the technology is there
there are a lot of people excited about
it and definitely the toolchains are
becoming much easier I have my son who
wants to do robotics and it's quite hard
to get started on it but I'm hoping you
know by the time he goes to middle
school he should be able to build these
autonomous systems and he could imagine
and he could build these things very
easily so you know if you're excited
about robotics and machine learning I
think there are stuff out there and I
would encourage everyone to come out and
you know play and contribute hmm go deep
last words you know humans overestimate
what can happen in three years and
underestimate what happens in 10 years
and we are embarking on another one of
those moments where I think 10 years
from now the world is gonna be very very
very different and it's inevitable so
it's not like you know it's slow down or
whatever I think we just have to lean in
and go really fast and free think some
of these things so that as the world
really adopts these things it is done in
a way that we can all survive it you
know I remind people that is so many
couple of years ago the iPhone was 10
years old and when the iPhone came out
nobody could have predicted how it
changed lives and I think you can say
that with the internet you can say that
with a personal computer and so many
things I think this is one of those
moments so we have to get into it both
getting ahead of it
leveraging it you know getting our kids
to be trained in these things and I
think we just have to get in a society
Kirti Paul Ashish Kapur thank you for
making episode 100 this fantastic thanks
for having us thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about how Microsoft is
working to bring emergent AI into real
world applications visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]